-Actually, you know what?
I think I pulled something
on that last joke.
I'm not sure I can go on,
actually.
But this is "The Tonight Show."
We have to go on.
I need someone to tag in for me.
Anyone? Can someone
tag in for me, please?
Oh, oh, hey.
Thank you. I appreciate it.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Man.
Thank you, thank you.
Great guy. Thank you.
I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause
continue ]
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause
continue ]
Thank you.
Very nice.
I've been standing back there
for nine months.
Folks, sexual harassment --
sexual harassment --
a big issue.
People finally
taking it seriously.
In fact, scientists
at Northwestern University
did a study
about the differences
between men's brains
and women's brains.
And this is fascinating.
Listen to this.
It seems women's brains
are located in their head.
I was...
This explains a lot.
And a lot of really talented
and really accomplished actors
have been accused
of sexual harassment.
Also, Steven Seagal.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, I was talking
about this
just yesterday
with my Uber driver,
Kevin Spacey.
That -- We were
talking about this...
Just telling you.
Yeah, we were talking about it.
Hey, and you know something?
Hey.
It's not --
It's not just actors.
Matthew Weiner, the creator
of the hit show "Mad Men" --
He's been accused.
And let me
tell you something, okay?
When your last name is Weiner...
[ Laughter ]
just introducing yourself
to people is sexual harassment.
[ Applause ]
And, I'm sure you know,
former Congressman
Anthony Weiner is in jail.
He's in jail
for sexting an underage girl.
And what you might not know is,
when he got caught,
he actually called Bill Clinton
to apologize.
See, that's when you know
your life
has gone off the rails.
When your sexual behavior
offends Bill Clinton, okay...
[ Laughter ]
Ooh.
Matt Lauer -- Matt Lauer
fired from the "Today" show.
And Matt had
to learn the hard way,
when Al Roker
says, "No," he means "no."
That --
And Charlie Ro--
How about Charlie Rose?
Walking around naked
in front of interns.
When did newsmen
start behaving like this?
I never met Walter Cronkite
prancing around
in front of Margaret Thatcher,
"Take a look at that, Margaret.
That's -- And that's
the way it is."
You know what I'm saying?
But see, now --
now people are discussing
levels of sexual harassment.
Like, on the low side
of the scale, you get the guys
that are just what I call
sexually annoying, you know?
Where everything a woman says
has a sexual connotation.
Like a woman might say,
"Bob, will you pass the salt?"
"I'll pass you salt.
You know what I'm talking about!
Yeah!"
And then, the other side,
you got Harvey Weinstein.
Oh, my God.
You've been following this guy?
He meets a woman
in a hotel lobby,
asks to go up to his room,
she says no.
He then opens his pants and
masturbates into a potted plant.
Now, admittedly,
I have been
out of the dating game
for a number of years.
[ Laughter ]
It's just hard to believe
the protocol
has changed that much.
And I got to ask the women,
has that ever worked?
-No!
-A guy hits on you, you say no,
he does that,
and you go,
"Oh, what a fool I was!"
[ Laughter ]
And how about Harvey?
Has he thought it through?
Let's say the woman
did change her mind.
The man is 65 years old.
By the time he was done
with the potted plant,
sweetheart, you're gonna have
to come back tomorrow.
But, hey --
Hey, you know -- Hey.
[ Applause ]
Luckily...
Luckily those are just media
types and Hollywood people.
Can you imagine what
our country would be like
if the President
of the United States
acted like that?
Oh, my...
[ Scattered laughter ]
As you know, President Trump
allegedly paid a porn star
$130,000 to cover up
their affair.
If that turns out to be true,
it'd be the first time
Trump has
fully compensated somebody
for all the work they did.
So that's pretty amazing.
That's pretty amazing.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Jay, thank you for helping me.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Thank you.
Thank you for helping me,
Jay Leno.
Thank you for helping me.